welcome to the hugging face task series
in this video we'll take a look at the
causal language modeling
causal language modeling is the task of
predicting the next word in a sentence
given all the previous words
this task is very similar to the
autocorrect function that you might have
on your
phone these models take a sequence to be
completed and outputs to complete
sequence
classification metrics can't be used as
there is no single correct answer for
the compilation
instead we evaluate the distribution of
the text completed by the model
a common metric to do so is the
cross-entropy loss
perplexity is also widely used metric
and it is calculated as the exponential
of the cross-entropy loss
you can use any data set with plain text
and tokenize the text to prepare the
data
causal language models can be used to
generate code
for more information about the causal
language modeling task check out the
hugging face course